En este vídeo quiero ver un montón de ejemplos de los dos tipos de
multiplicaciones de binomios que te vas a encontrar más frecuentemente en álgebra. El primero es elevar al cuadrado, por ejemplo que nos pidan determinar
algo de la forma "x" más 9 y eso elevado al cuadrado.
La primer tentación es decir que esto es igual a "x" al cuadrado más 9 al cuadrado pero esto está mal.
No hay que caer en esa tentación,
déjame quitarlo
¿Va? Entonces no es igual a eso, para saber a que es igual tenemos que acordarnos que quiere decir elevar algo al cuadrado y
simplemente es multiplicar en este caso este binomio
por sí mismo, por "x" más 9 ¿Va? Esto de aquí ya lo podemos desarrollar para ver qué nos queda.
Déjame hacerlo, lo voy a hacer con multiplicación larga entonces aquí voy a poner "x" más 9
y aquí abajo voy a multiplicar por "x" más 9 lo voy a poner
así con colores, para poder ir siguiendo
cada término ¿Vale?
Y entonces hacemos la multiplicación,
primero empezamos con este 9, 9 por 9 81
más 81,  9 por equis es 9x
luego vamos con la "x", "x" por 9 también es 9x y "x" por "x" es "x" al cuadrado
y entonces el resultado, el resultado de hacer la multiplicación
sería "x" al cuadrado, "x" al cuadrado, lo voy a poner con otro color.
Sería "x" al cuadrado más 18x, 18x más
81. Creo que aquí más o menos se ve un patrón ¿Verdad? Le voy a poner aquí que es igual a
"x" al cuadrado más 18x más 81,
entonces ahorita te voy a decir exactamente cuál es el patrón pero, vamos a pensarlo tantito o sea ¿Que es lo que sucedió?
Que apareció pues ve apareció el "x" al cuadrado que viene de multiplicar esta "x" con esta "x"
apareció el 81 que viene de multiplicar los 9, y además apareció este 18x y ¿De dónde vino?
Pues vino de este 9x y este 9x que eran igualitos ¿Verdad? Entonces sumando 9x con 9x
nos quedó igual a
18x ¿Va? Vamos a hacerlo un poco más en general para ver realmente cómo es el patrón. Entonces déjame poner
que queremos determinar
"x" más "b" al cuadrado donde "b"
vamos a pensarlo horita como constante ¿Vale? Como en este ejemplo de acá, solo que es cualquier
constante. Bueno vamos a realizar la multiplicación para ver que nos queda. A ver la voy a poner por acá "x" más b
multiplicado por "x" más  y en color verde "b" ¿Ok? Entonces ¿Qué nos queda?
"b" por "b" es "b" cuadrada "b" por "x" es xb lo voy a poner así xb.
¿Vale? Luego "x" por "b" también es xb
y "x" por "x" es "x" al cuadrado, entonces la respuesta
para esta multiplicación es
"x" al cuadrado,
más aquí tenemos 2xb más 2xb
más "b" al cuadrado ¿Vale? Entonces ve aquí ya se ve clarísimo, clarísimo en qué consiste elevar al cuadrado un binomio.
Es poner el primer término al cuadrado luego 2 veces el producto de ambos términos,
y finalmente el segundo término al cuadrado. Vamos a ver algunos ejemplos más para agarrar práctica ¿Vale?
Imagínate que queremos, que queremos encontrar
3x -7, 3x -7
al cuadrado ¿Cómo le haríamos?
Pues bueno vamos a utilizar la formulita, el primero al cuadrado 2 dos veces el primero por el segundo más el segundo al cuadrado.
Bueno ahí ya sonaba que estamos haciendo memorización ¿Verdad? Está bueno para velocidad pero es bueno siempre, es bueno tener en cuenta
pues de dónde viene. Viene de utilizar la propiedad distributiva pero, bueno vamos a hacerlo. Vamos a ver qué nos queda.
Sería el primero al cuadrado. el primero es 3x, 3x al cuadrado.
Luego más 2 veces el primer término por el segundo, el primero es 3x
3x y luego estamos sumando un -7 bueno estamos restando un 7 pero eso es lo mismo que sumar un -7
¿Va? Entonces es por -7 y luego sumamos -7 al cuadrado, -7 al cuadrado, vamos a ver cuánto nos queda
simplificando,
3x al cuadrado pues utilizando leyes de los exponentes y así sería
9x al cuadrado más 2 por 3 es 6, 6 por 7 es 42 pero, aquí hay un menos entonces más bien debía haber puesto -42x
y luego hay que sumar -7 al cuadrado que es 49
49 ¿Va? Entonces nos queda 9x al cuadrado -42x más 49 y bueno este fue un método un poco más rápido.
Déjame verificarlo con la división larga tradicional para ver que de a de veras sí
da eso. Lo voy a poner por acá es "x" -7
otra vez en colores le voy a poner 3x -7.
Entonces vamos a hacerlo también así, para ver qué nos queda exactamente lo mismo.
-7 por -7 es más 49
luego - 7 por 3x es -21x
¿Ok? Luego vamos con el morado 3x con -7 es -21x y finalmente 3x
multiplicado con 3x pues es 9x al cuadrado.
Vamos a ver qué nos queda sumando estos dos, nos debería dar lo mismo. Aquí es 9x al cuadrado -42x
más 49 y sí, sí da exactamente lo mismo ¿Verdad? Muy bien vamos a hacer, vamos a hacer uno más para agarrar así mucha práctica.
Ahora lo vamos a hacer con un poquito más de variables, déjame ponerlo de este lado,
de este lado. Imagínate que nos piden encontrar 4x al cuadrado más
me voy a poner aquí un "y" cuadrado, elevado al cuadrado es exactamente la misma idea que en los ejemplos anteriores,
tenemos que tomar el primero y elevarlo al cuadrado, sería 4x al cuadrado, elevado al cuadrado
más 2 veces 4x cuadrada por "y" cuadrada
es el producto de los 2, 2 veces más el segundo "y" cuadrada,
elevado al cuadrado ¿Muy bien? Vamos a ver qué nos queda, simplificando esto es igual a
4 al cuadrado es 16, "x" al cuadrado es
"x" al cuadrado al cuadrado es "x" a la cuarta entonces es 16x a la cuarta
más 2 por 4 es 8
"x" cuadrada "y" cuadrada
"x" cuadrada "y" cuadrada más "y" cuadrado al cuadrado, más "y" a la cuarta, "y" a la cuarta
¿Muy bien? Entonces ya sabemos elevar un binomio al cuadrado, ya somos expertos. Ahora vamos a pasar a otro tipo de producto especial,
que tiene que ver con multiplicar la suma de 2 números con su resta, y este de  aquí sale muy bonito, déjame hacerlo en general.
Imagínate que nos piden de hacer la multiplicación "a" más "b", "a" más "b" por "a" menos "b".
Entonces es la suma de dos números
multiplicada con su resta entonces, déjame ver qué nos queda vamos a hacerlo,
multiplicando cada uno de los términos ¿Va? Entonces sería "a" por éste "a",
sería "a" él "a" morado por él "a" verde,
luego "a" por este -"b" entonces aquí va con menos y sería ab,
luego "b" con este "a" aquí es más entonces sería más ba
y finalmente tenemos que restar "b" morado con "b" verde ¿Vale? "b" morado con "b" verde
pero esto de los colores es nada más medio artificial verdad para poder ir siguiendo,
en realidad podemos simplificar la expresión que nos quedaría ya
simplificada pues eso sería igual a déjame ponerlo con este color azul bonito,
entonces igual a aquí tenemos "a" por "a" es "a" cuadrada
luego -ab es -ab,
luego más ba pues lo voy a poner como más ab nada más cambia el orden de los factores,
- "b" por "b" - b cuadrada y entonces reescribiendo esto bueno
simplificando, podemos cancelar este ab con este ab por que aquí tiene signo menos y nos queda igual a "a" cuadrada
-b cuadrada y esto está bien bonito por que simplifica las cosas en muchos casos. Vamos a hacer un ejemplo
vamos a hacer un ejemplo de esto. Imagínate que nos piden
multiplicar 2x - 1
con 2x más 1, con 2 x más 1.
Entonces bueno aquí puse primero la resta, éste lo podemos pensar como "a" - "b" éste lo podemos pensar como "a" más "b",
entonces "a" es 2 x "b" es 1 y entonces nos queda igual a
Igual a "a" al cuadrado o sea 2x al cuadrado
-"b" al cuadrado "b" es 1 entonces es - 1 al cuadrado que es igual a 4
x al cuadrado -1.
Muy bien nada más vamos a hacer un último ejemplo, con un poquito más de variables para ver qué es exactamente lo mismo.
Imagínate que nos piden la
multiplicación 5a -2b
con 5a más 2b.
¿Va? Una vez más es la suma de 2 números por la diferencia, eso es súper importante
que estemos en ese caso ¿Si? Como vimos arriba un binomio al cuadrado se hace de otra forma y multiplicar otros binomios también
pero, ahorita tenemos que hacerlo con la suma y la resta.
Siempre en la duda es mejor utilizar la propiedad
distributiva ¿Sale? Pero bueno ahorita si aplica es "a" más "b" por "a" - "b" y entonces nos quedaría igual a
el primero al cuadrado o sea
25a al cuadrado, bueno déjame ponerlo paso a paso entonces, 5a al cuadrado
- el segundo al cuadrado -2b al cuadrado y esto nos queda igual a 25a cuadrada
-4b cuadrada muy bien. Voy a dejarle hasta aquí en este vídeo nos vemos hasta la próxima.